في حال بقيت شميمه بغوم المعروفه بعروس
داعش في سوريا ستشكل خطرا كبيرا على الامن
القومي البريطاني تصريح محير جاء على لسان
رئيس جهاد الاستخبارات البريطاني السابق
ريتشارد باريس الذي سجل رايا مخالفا تماما
لكل التحضيرات السابقه حول عوده الشابه
البالغه من العمر 23 عاما من مخيم الهوى
لعائلات تنظيم داعش في سوريا المدير
السابق لجهازي مكافحه الارهاب العالميه
التابع لجهاز الاستخبارات
البريطاني ام اي 5 وام اي 6 وصفت تقييم
وهو المكتب الخامس في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطاني حول المخاطر الامنيه التي قد
تستعيلها عروس داعش السطحيه وغير الملائم
وبقائها قال بانه بمخيم داعش يهدد امن
البلاد وحرمانها من جنسيتها كفرد من دون
اي تفسير لكيفيه تحولها من فتاه مراهقه
الى عضو في تنظيم ارهابي هو امر مخيف
المدير السابق لجهازي مكافحه الارهاب
العالمي شدد ايضا على ان بلاده قدمت
استجابه مختلفه عن بقيه الدول لمشكله
اعاده المواطنين الذين سافروا للانضمام
الى داعش مقارنه بالولايات المتحده
والمانيا وفرنس شميمه بيقوم موجوده الان
في مخيم لنازحه عائلات تنظيم داعش في شمال
شرق سوريا
وتحاول شهيده اليوم طلب السماح من بلادها
والعفو عنها واسترداد جنسيتها محامو عروس
داعش في بريطانيا الاسبوع الماضي بقرار
الحكومه البريطانيه لتجريدها من الجنسيه
امام محكمه في لندن اعتبر انها كانت طفله
طفله ضحيه للتهريب لانها كانت في الخامسه
عشر من عمرها عندما غادرت لندن عام 2015
مع اثنتين من رفيقاتها ليتزوجها لاحقا احد
مقاتلي داعش وتنجب منه ثلاثه اطفال توفوا
جميعا وهم في سن الرضاعه وخلال جلسه
الاستئناف كشف محامها ايضا انه تم الاتجار
بها لغرض الاستغلال الجنسي من قبل مقاتل
داعش